do you want to talk about biden saying
that facebook is killing people
yeah that was interesting so set that up
mark so
basically i don't know the full full
context but i just know that
biden's secretary of the press came out
and was saying all this stuff like
accusing facebook and maybe trying to
even sue facebook a little redhead joint
yeah her name is christina saccas
pasakis or i don't know i remember when
she was at band camp doing some wild
[ __ ]
because she was at band camp yeah yeah
yeah that's a good reference you're
getting wild with the flute
yo shorty was getting wild with the
flute that's a great thing
yeah but yeah tell tell me what the
unbreakable kimmy schmidt was talking
about
basically uh they were saying that
facebook is allowing misinformation to
disseminate through their platform yeah
and it's killing people
what is the quote yeah facebook is
killing people yeah
i don't know if they're responsible for
killing people but yeah a hundred
percent the
people die as a result of misinformation
and uh but then you could also say like
is is what is their net
like do they have net positive are more
people living because of the things that
they read on facebook
right right like are there are there you
know grandparents that are able to like
have relationships with their kids and
grandkids and
that's giving them more motivation to
stay alive like might even be a direct
like covet thing like there's certain
people that might not have gotten the
vaccine then they saw a bunch of things
like oh no you can still dive you
if you don't get it and they're like all
right fine i'll get it or even a place
where they could get the shot
right yeah they had no clue where they
go get it and then oh wow they see their
friends getting in they're like oh maybe
it's safe
and it's tricky because how do you how
do you decide what's misinformation and
what's not
yeah now you're playing big brother for
real if you're an information platform
that information is going to lead to
happiness it's going to lead to
depression like
i don't know if you're responsible for
all the feelings and outcomes
that happen because of your platform
yeah but if you want to talk about lives
lost like yeah sure [ __ ] died
because of facebook like
how many people how many how many
people's locations
have been shared and then they just got
murdered as the result of instagram or
facebook that should just happen
with whom uh there was this i think it
was a [ __ ] out in l.a
and yeah he no actually it was a blood
out pop smoke
yeah he decimated like um [ __ ] who was a
rapper that died the baby oh yeah
um the marathon continues snipsy hustle
you don't know [ __ ] about raps academics
desecrated his grave and then he was on
ig
live and then boys shot him live and he
died on ig lot
ratings through the roof oh my god
ratings through the roof
facts though right this is crazy that's
true you gotta be his most watched live
probably you don't think you're gonna go
watch that replay iron if they call it
live
igb you think somebody had the foresight
why at the end when it's over it says do
you want to record this and keep it live
[Laughter]
but that is crazy like a lot of people
end up dying because of the platform is
it the platform's responsibility or
fault
i don't know the tricky thing i think
when it comes to like misinformation is
is that there are algorithms that um
react and promote
certain things that are being digested
that's the fear thing okay so break it
down well that's
exactly what we're talking about the
media is that like our brains are in the
forest they're programmed to be looking
at threats yeah and so when you're on
social media and you see
like oh the vaccine is actually going to
[ __ ] give you cancer you're like oh
god damn it i gotta watch it yeah i
gotta watch it i'm gonna share it
because i don't want my friends to get
sick and so like you're now passing
around all the misinformation why am i
so threatened by girls with huge tits
jumping
[Laughter]
why is that why is that so threatening
sounds like an amazing time
because that that pops up on your issue
that pops up on my thing because of fear
yeah i am terrified yeah if there's a
girl with huge tits jumping
yeah i can you fear for her safety i
feel like what about her back is it
gonna hurt her
you're the biggest feminist i know i
think anybody knows you know
you are really concerned share it with
your friends so that way you know we can
also
yeah exactly because that kind of
information needs to be shared you can
tell other hot girls are huge shits like
hey
guys be careful be mindful of how you
move
yeah that is true because in this way
instagram is actually saving people's
lives
yes right yes i mean a lot of them
mm-hmm
but also killing people too probably
yeah at least a billion of um potential
people
maybe big chiropracty or whatever the
[ __ ] you call it he's trying to tell
these girls to do it
they're trying to tell these girls hey
you should jump up and down chiropractic
we got to stop science you know what i
mean you guys say hey they're just
trying to make money off the treatment
maybe he's playing on something in your
brain maybe
like uh maybe like you have a fear of
starving and you see like a voluptuous
woman and anything you could suckle on
her on her teeth is it volumptuous or
voluptuous it's voluptuous the m really
threw me off
because that's stupid learn how to
[ __ ] speak
[ __ ] honestly all the creatine
you're taking making you dumber
[Laughter]
that's what it is there's some real
balloon
you make scrumptious and voluptuous
together it's a new word into a way
better word
yeah okay so takeaway
is facebook killing people possibly
probably
probably yeah or are people dying as a
result of facebook yes that's a better
way but are people
living as a result of facebook instagram
yes
are they net positive net negative i
don't know probably net negative in
terms of how they make us feel
but they might be net positive in life
how and so how in life like we all feel
a little bit worse but we are
more connected yeah so maybe those
connections lead to like
i don't know less suicides or some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like
bitcoin
[Laughter]
we hope so what is it so so do you hold
them accountable is biden just being a
[ __ ] when he does this [ __ ]
it's a little cuckish but it's also not
fully wrong like you said
and then as we were trying to name net
positive things we couldn't really think
of any
i mean connectivity my career huge yeah
yeah yeah your career all of our careers
are huge and they're positive
yeah we're gonna bring life into this
world because of social media yeah yeah
youtube's not facebook
facebook helps sue well it all helps but
connect
connectivity is uh [ __ ] sorry boomers
you old ass
you know what i mean watching my clips
on facebook sorry boomer
yeah i using your knees and watching
some facebook clips
the old [ __ ] dude what
what al we over a million on facebook oh
[ __ ]
sorry we over a million on facebook yeah
but yeah
what no this is just a fascinating thing
that they say that apparently 12 people
are behind
most covid vaccine hoaxes on social
media
what's the hoax that's what i understand
like so it's just like putting out
misinformation so like what what
misinformation exists on vaccines
give me one give me one bit of
misinformation though
i don't even think misinformation exists
on vaccines dead ass
let's go let's go throw me one let's
cook does the vaccine make it rain
does vaccine make rain outside no what
give me one bit of mystery
go go this is gonna be fun that's all
episodes getting taken down but uh
i think i mean one thing people said
that like there could be a sterilization
as a result of of vaccine use oh so that
you can't get girls pregnant
yeah on the girls side or on the due
side i don't know i don't know bro some
[ __ ] facebook hey
do we know that it can't be
we don't know it's gonna be your reply
to all this [ __ ] i'm just saying we
don't know yet the [ __ ] just came out
right like you don't know until it goes
for a little bit
right like people gotta use the lotion
before they find out it gives them
cancer
and at the johnson and johnson [ __ ] yeah
i just [ __ ] up because i'm using that
[ __ ] too
yeah yeah that's why you were sweating
so much i still got that book bag right
[Applause]
now
you